glen what's going on what's up how you
doing good to see you too i mean how
does it feel to be here representing
dancing with the stars at the mtv awards
it feels amazing i mean we've been
nominated our show has been going for so
long and it's such a yeah it's such a
cool moment you know
hopefully we can win yeah you want that
golden popcorn i know god damn um talk
to me about dancing moving to disney
plus what did you make of all that what
was your reaction
i think it's such a cool
transition you know um
we have disney week we have a halloween
so it's all like a disney
weeks and disney moments we've been
having on the show for so long so moving
to disney plus
kind of like gives us a different
opportunity to be even closer to disney
you know we've been for the last couple
of seasons we've been shooting
um opening numbers and like huge group
numbers at disneyland actually
disneyland like shut down the whole
thing so
it's awesome i think it's such a new
great transition i'm i'm super excited
i'm looking forward to it so now are you
returning next season can we plan on
seeing you on disney plus
fingers crossed who knows i know you
love the show i love the show i love the
show it's been doing it all my life so
of course is my life well i got to ask
you obviously you've made the headlines
recently with about your former partner
janet is there anything you want to
clear up there we you know
there's a lot of uh there's a lot of
acting there's a lot of chemistry
natural chemistry and you know when you
dance and you train someone every day
uh
and you're up close and personal and uh
you you develop a certain connection the
viewer see it you know and you want to
have that because you want to last at
the competition my job is to
make sure that we go really really far
have we ever had anything absolutely not
absolutely no whatever she might have
said it to her boyfriend maybe she tried
to make him jealous you know you can ask
her the same question she'll probably
answer the same thing you know
and i i just you know i just feel a
little sad that he had to
go that way and say something like that
you know
her i was totally surprised she texted
me she's like dude like can you imagine
he said all of this i've never you know
like she
whatever so but
absolutely no yeah how's janna taking
that kind of like response and the
reaction to all of that
she said listen if there's a all-star
season i'm coming back and dance with
you right yeah
i'm not scared to come back onto the
ballroom floor
[Music]
yeah you